foreign
[Laughter]
talking to us about graph on games
further please go ahead okay so thank
you so much for the introduction and
thank you for the invite really a
pleasure to be here today
um so what I'm gonna do in this talk is
tell you a little bit about
um my research in the last few years
which really was about understanding
strategic behavior in large network
settings and I guess the relation to
this Workshop is that in order to do
that we're going to use graphones
okay so um let me start with just a
brief motivation of why are we
interested in that
um and really that comes from the
observation that in many social and
economic settings individuals make
strategic decisions but this decision
are not made in isolation they depends
on decision of their friends their
colleagues and peers as given by an
underlying Network
and there's many examples of that you
can think about adoption of innovation
and behavior opinion formation public
good provision or competition among
firms and now it's clear that you know
being able to understand what is the
outcome of this strategic interaction in
network environments it's really
important if we want to understand how
to intervene on this system maybe you
know to maximize the performance or the
profit of the overall wildfire
now in the last decade the framework of
Network games has emerged as a very
powerful framework to model this type of
strategic interaction in network
environments and so this is kind of the
framework that I'm going to use
throughout the talk today
so what I'm going to assume is I have a
population of Agents I'm gonna denote
capital N the number of agents that I
have in my population and these agents
are interacting over a network and G is
going to be the adjacency Matrix of this
network
now what every agents want to do is
select a strategy X I should think of
this kind of as a vector among a certain
feasible set calligraphic X in order to
minimize a cost function
now what makes this a game is the fact
that this cost function doesn't depend
only on the strategy of the agent and
maybe some local parameter but
importantly depends on the strategies of
the other players
and in fact what makes this a network
game is that I can summarize the fact
that the rest of the population has on a
certain agent I with this quantity z i
of X which really you should think as a
local aggregate so what I'm doing here
and I'm averaging over all my population
the strategy of Agent J weighted by the
local parameter that tells me how much
Agent J influences agent I
okay and as I mentioned here we are in a
game theoretical setting right so each
agent is doing its own optimization but
it's coupled because of this
interdependence so the relevant concept
of outcome is that of a Nash equilibrium
so what is a Nash equilibrium it's just
a set of strategies where no agent has
any interest in unilateral deviations so
if I look at my cost function by playing
the strategy prescribed by the Nash
equilibrium that's the minimum cost I
can get if I change to some other
feasible strategy I will get a higher
cost so I don't want to do that
what is what is he
data is some local parameter because
here my cost function doesn't depend on
I so if I want to have a heterogeneity
among agents I just gonna have some
local parameter here
it's just to allow cost function to be
different for different agents but this
is something local really the
interesting part happens here where the
coupling with the other agents happens
okay and this actually may be a little
bit clearer now that I go into simple
example of Network games
um so one uh simple case is that of
linear quadratic Network games this is
something that mentioned in the boot
camp
um so here every agent has a strategy
which is just a non-negative scholar and
so what this non-iotics color represent
is how much effort this agent is putting
on a certain activity then think of it
kind of education or not smoking
and the point is that the agents want to
select this effort level in order to
minimize a cost function which is linear
quadratic and it's composed by two parts
right the first part is the cost that
I'm gonna have because I put a certain
amount of effort and clearly the more
effort I put the higher the cost is
going to be
but then why do I want to do that
because I'm going to get some benefit
out of it and this is the second part
and in linear quadratic games the nice
thing is that the marginal return so the
return or the benefit that I get per
unit of my effort x i
is on a fine function of the network
aggregate so you see now why other
people actually matter their choices
because my return is going to depend on
their decision and in this simple case
in an assigned way weighted by this
parameter Alpha which is called the peer
effect parameter
okay so this is kind of one very nice
example where you know the strategy set
is no negative scholar you can also make
the strategies that discrete so you can
think of for example agents having only
two possible actions so maybe zero one
representing whether I adopt an
innovation or not or a buy a product or
not
um and then you can have agents play for
example a coordination game so just very
high level what does this mean say for a
moment you only have two player it means
I have an incentive to coordinate my
action with the action of the other
players so if we both choose one or if
we both choose zero we got some positive
reward
um otherwise we'll get zero now you can
think of this in a network setting where
I'm playing these you know two by two
game with each one of my neighbors you
can convince yourself that you know the
best thing that you can do in this game
is gonna be a threshold policy where you
adopt action one if enough of your
neighbors also have option one and
otherwise you stick with action zero
okay and I as I mentioned these are just
you know two a possible example of
Network games the theory that I'm gonna
do applies to the general framework that
I've discussed before
okay so what is a key question in this
area of literature is well what is the
impact that is underlying Network
structure has on the equilibrium outcome
and this is a question that's been
investigated a lot in the literature for
example people ask you know how my
position in the network gonna determine
what is going to be my action at
equilibrium and this started with this
seminal paper here where they look at
the linear quadratic Network model and
they show there is a nice connection
between equilibrium and centrality
measures so really like your position in
the network it's important for your
equilibrium action so for the existence
of an equilibrium is this condition x i
greater than equal to zero important so
in the previous slide you had a
condition x i greater than equal to 0.
so no no no no no this is just one
example you're going to see in a minute
conditions for existence and uniqueness
but you know in general I'm gonna work
in this framework here where this is any
Vector thanks
um so this is kind of relating you know
position agents um to the equilibrium
action and then you can even ask you
know I'm from a controlled background so
maybe I want to intervene on this system
so I can ask the question where if a
central planner want to intervene on
this system can you exploit information
about the network to do some type of
targeted intervention
and again this is kind of a general
question that's been looked by many
people in different setting again like
from this seminal paper in the context
of crime application they look at you
know which player should I remove in
order to decrease the criminal activity
the most uh but then this has also been
applied to
um optimal pricing if you want to sell a
good for example should you give
different prices to different people
depending on their Network position if
you want to maximize well like reward
um or this is a paper that Ben mentioned
in the boot camp this is like if you
want to allocate a certain budget but
your budget is limited how do you do
that to maximize welfare
um and then finally this is kind of in
the coordination game that I mentioned
before say you can kind of give this
product for free to some agents which
one should you choose such that at the
end
um the most of the agents will actually
buy your product
now one thing that I want to stress
however is all this paper that I've kind
of mentioned now they require the
central planner to have exact Network
information right if you want to compute
this type of intervention you need to
know how the agents are interacting
and this is kind of bringing me to the
motivation for the type of research that
I've been doing in past few years
which is what happens when we go to very
large Networks now if you think of it
like you know from a practical
perspective two problems emerge like the
first problem is that you know
collecting exact Network information
becomes extremely costly or may not
possible due to privacy constraints
uh and the second problem is that you
know even if you had this exact Network
information Computing the optimal
intervention will become computationally
intractable some of this problem that I
mentioned before they are MP half so you
can solve it if the network is small but
when the network is very big you don't
know how to do
that so really this is kind of the key
question for this talk which is how can
we regulate strategic behavior when we
are in these large network settings
and the key observation uh where I'm
going to build on is that you know even
though the central planner may not have
exact information about the network of
interactions it may have some
information about the likelihood that
different agents will interact with each
other which it can be used to infer like
a stochastic Network formation model or
I guess in the language of this Workshop
a random Network model right model
and so in line with what you've seen the
type of random graph model that I'm
going to consider is that of graphons so
again symmetric measurable function W
map is 0 1 square into zero one and as
you all know there's kind of two
different ways in which you can see
graphers right the first is as a limit
of a graph when number of nodes tends to
Infinity
um the interpretation that I'm gonna use
today is actually the second one so in
terms of random graph mode so again the
idea is that I can sample random graphs
from my graphene model how do I do that
well you all know it like you take your
finite number of Agents you assign a
label to each one of these agents which
is just a uniform in zero one and then
you connect every agents with Bernoulli
probability that comes from the graphone
evaluated at the labels
okay
um and okay I should mention that of
course the theory of graphone has been
very well developed by people in this
audience and well understood so really
the contribution of this work is going
to be to kind of build on this Theory to
try to understand you know strategic
behavior in large network settings
so this is kind of the picture that I
want you to have in mind so what we are
doing here is going from a deterministic
approach where analysis and intervention
are based on exact network data to a
stochastic approach where what I'm going
to assume is that I have a stochastic
Network formation model this can
generate different random graph the one
observing reality is going to be one
realization from this stochastic night
performation model and what I want to
know is well can I still analyze
behavior and plan intervention if I only
have information about the generating
model
so to kind of reformulate the question
I'm going to focus on so-called sample
Network games which are Network games
exactly as I described at the beginning
of this talk that are going to be played
over a network that's been sampled in
this case from a graph
so really the question is can we
regulate strategy behavior in the sample
Network games
and in order to make progress on this
I'm going to focus on smooth and convex
game so the strategy set is going to be
Compact and convex cost function is
going to be strongly convex in your own
strategy and with a gradient that is lip
sheets in the local hardware and these
are kind of Fairly standard assumptions
uh towards the end of the talk maybe
I'll discuss when these are not met
okay so this brings me to the really the
talk outline
um so again our objective here is
understanding what happens
um for large settings so the first step
is gonna be to try to understand what
happens to the Nash equilibrium in this
case and to do that I'm actually going
to take two steps again what we want is
large setting so the first thing is I'm
gonna take the limit and just look at an
infinite population
and so in order to do that I'm going to
introduce this tool of graphone games
which is going to allow me to describe
strategic interaction for infinite
populations
then as I mentioned what I'm interested
is actually what happens for finite
sample Network so as a second step I'm
going to try to relate the equilibrium
in this infinite population game to the
equilibrium that I can observe in any of
the realized sample Network game and I'm
going to try to convince you that this
is a good approximation if your
population is large enough
so this is kind of a nice convergence
result of course the question that you
can ask afterwards is why is this
interesting
um and so that's going to be kind of the
second part just just to put it into the
context of the previous talk so the
difference is that in the previous talk
on each node you had sort of a Continuum
of Agents where you only have a
Continuum of Agents into limit yeah so
every node here is an agent a single age
and then I'm just gonna take a limit in
the infinite population so that's one
difference the other difference is that
Peter was talking about Dynamic gains
the games I presented are static games
right so every agent just has a strategy
that needs to choose that it's a vector
Over N it doesn't need to choose a
control over time right these are static
names okay
okay so second part I'm gonna try to
illustrate why this kind of convergence
result is interesting I'm gonna do that
for control talking about intervention
design and also for identification
talking about parameter estimations and
then finally if there is time I will go
to some extension because this theory
that I'm going to present holds under
the assumption of existence uniqueness
of the national equilibrium you can ask
what happens if the Nash equilibrium is
not unique so we have some result in
that
um and then the last part again if there
is time we will look at coordination
games where remember the actions that is
discrete that's of course not a complex
set so you cannot apply this Theory to
that case foreign
okay so let me go to the first part
again this is about graphing game and
this is some work that I started during
my postcard MIT together with asthma
Stabler
okay so the first step if you remember
as I told you is let's take the limit
let's just look at what happens if I
have an infinite population so this is
the framework of Network games for
finite population that I've already
explained to you here I have a finite
number of regions one to one
um we'll now want to send that to
infinite population and the way you do
that is actually have to take quite
trivial so you're now going to consider
a Continuum of Agents mapping the zero
one interval and exactly as before every
agents want to select a strategy to
minimize a cost function this is exactly
as before the only thing that's going to
be different is how you compute the
local aggregate right in final Network
game that was a sum overall my agents
using as weight the way it's coming from
the graph now of course since I have an
infinite population this is going to
become an integral and I'm gonna use as
weights the way it's coming from the
graph
exactly as before we can define a
concept of Nash equilibrium so this is a
strategy profile where no agent has any
interest in unilateral deviations
the only thing that is slightly
different here is that this strategy
profile is now going to be a function
right that tells me for each one of my
agent in zero one what is the action
that this agent is taking
and as it already came up like the first
thing that you asked is well does this
exist this is even a well-defined
concept and is it unique or not and so
this is exactly like our first result
and in order to formulate that I need to
introduce the graphene operator and I
like to think of this as kind of like
the equivalent to the adjacent
symmetrics when you go from finite to
infinite populations so this is kind of
a linear integral operator where the
kernel is given by the graphene
and again this is a linear operator so
you can Define spectral property of it
and it turns out that if you impose a
condition on the maximum eigenvalue of
this operator you can guarantee
existence and uniqueness
um and I guess for the ones that are not
expert in Game Theory I just put here a
sketch of the proof uh
yes these are kind of the
convexity strong convexity parameter and
lipsticks this comes from my my game
being smooth and Compass so these are
kind of this has to do basically with
the connectivity and this has to do with
the cost function regularity of the cost
function
um okay and you're actually going to see
it in a minute why is that because how
do we prove this well we prove it
studying the best response mapping and
this is a very standard approach in Game
Theory so what is the best response
mapping that's a map that goes you know
from the uh space of all the possible
strategy profile to the same space and
so if I give you a strategy profile x
what is best response is gonna do is
return a new strategy profile X Prime
where every agent is selecting the best
possible strategy to minimize its cost
function when the local aggregate is
computed according to the initial
strategy profile
and why is this interesting or a very
key thing in Game Theory because it is
very well known that any Nash
equilibrium profile is a fixed point of
this response mapping and vice versa so
I can really just study the fixed point
of the best response mapping
and so what we've shown is that under
this condition here this best response
mapping is actually a contraction so you
get existence and uniqueness by Bannock
explain Theory and again like this
condition here if you move this to the
right let me write this as less than one
is exactly what you need for having a
contraction good question yes
hi thanks do you know anything about
whether the necessity of this condition
or you know
uh no because sometimes you can get
these things even without the
contraction right yeah this is unique
absolutely like I mean
we haven't derived it okay I think like
this is definitely not necessary it's a
sufficient condition
s
so it's equivalent to the contract yes
yes exactly
the problem that we are interested in
however is what happens when I sample a
network a finite Network for my graph
phone and look at equilibrium over that
Network and when I'm gonna try to
convince you now is that the equilibria
in the sample Network games are actually
converging to the equilibrium in the
graphene so this is kind of a good
approximation as long as I have a large
enough population
and so this is a little bit the result
uh more formally so what I can say here
is that you know under some regularity
condition I can with Pro with any
desired probability upper bound the
distance between the graph and
equilibrium this x bar and the
equilibrium in the sample Network this x
Bar N with some quantity that goes to
zero when n goes to Infinity
and now you may some of you have a
puzzled paste at this point because I
told you like in finite Network games
the equilibrium is a vector right but in
infinite population is a function so
this is kind of not exactly well defined
uh but the main idea here of the proof
is that you can take any finite Network
game and map that into an auxiliary
graph on game where the graphene is the
empirical graphene right so you it's a
piecewise constant graph on where every
piece corresponds to a link in your
finite Network
oh
the network that you are using is
directly sampled from the graph one
right it is not like you have a network
that is converging to them no okay no
that's why I say that focus on the
second interpretation as well I mean you
can do it that way as well but I I like
it more in the context of strategy games
to just sample from it
um okay so why is this interesting
because now I can compare you know
equilibrium sample Network games and
graph on games by comparing equilibrium
to graphone games one over the original
graphone and one over this empirical
graphone and I would say the key of this
proof is this second step here that
shows that you have some continuity in
the graphene so you can actually after
bound the distance between equilibrium
of two graph on game by the distance or
the corresponding graph on operator
I have I'm a little confused about that
because your ex one of them is defined
on the vertices one is defined on the
continuum
and you have to decide
which little intervals you map to which
vertex because if you align I cannot
give you an okay so what we are doing
here is because we have these lipsticks
condition here we are taking order
statistics so once I sample of my agents
I actually order them and that's why I
get this result but if you don't want to
do that you want to do the standard one
then you can actually have exactly the
same result but where you're gonna have
here kind of an in overall the measure
preserving permutation and then you can
do it with the standard
but that's where I'm a little confused
because are they always compatible
so you say you just so I order my agents
by their label yes and then the interval
I give to an agent is oh but you also
say I order the equilibrium
the X in the continuuma also this is
ordered according like no this is like
the graph one right according to the
graphone then I sample so so the
decrease of the graph on r nowhere
constant and then you order no I don't I
don't even need to order the graph the
graph one is given and but your strategy
is I just need to order my agents when I
sample them right like if you think the
standard result you have just one
measure like you promote only one here
and promoting the sample one
foreign
then you can get exactly the same result
you're just gonna have an if here
overall measure preserving permutation
and this is going to apply to the
tenfold one right and then you can apply
exactly that you read it
yeah
okay
um and so once I have this pretty much
undone right because I reduce my problem
of comparing the distance of the
equilibrium to the distance of the
graphene operator but this is my
original graph one and this is the
empirical graphone corresponding to a
sample Network so you know that you can
upper bound this by something that goes
to zero when angles to Infinity that's
kind of you're assembling them
okay so basically what have we
established here is that you know if I
have large enough population instead of
looking at the equilibrium over the
sample Network which requires me to know
exactly the network realization I can
just look at the equilibrium over the
graphing game so what I want to do in
the second part is actually
um tell you a little bit on why this
result is interested in some practical
problems and so for that I'm going to
actually start with intervention design
um and here the type of question I'm
glad to address is can I use this
convergence result to find new ways in
which design intervention for my game
that are near optimal but most
importantly computationally tractable
when I have large populations
and so to kind of make this a little bit
more concrete I'm going to focus on this
particular intervention design problem
where I have a central planner that can
modify this heterogeneity parameter
Theta I from Theta I to Theta I plus
Theta hat I and he wants to do so in
order to maximize the welfare of the
population at equilibrium so for those
of you that don't know the welfare that
is just minus the sum of the cost
functions so I'm trying to kind of make
all my agents happy
um and what is the problem here is that
my central planner has a limited budget
for this intervention so he needs to
decide how to split it among all the
agents
now this program that I brought down
here is the program for the sample
Network right so in order to solve this
you need to know the network uh and the
other problem is that it scales with n i
need to decide exactly what intervention
to give to each one of my agents
so solving this problem is actually
computational intractable if you have
more than a few hundreds of Agents
now if your game is a special structure
like this linear quadratic game that I
mentioned at the beginning Ben kind of
presented some insight of how you
actually can compute the solution based
on spectral properties of your network
an apology with the phrase computational
interactable we can mean lots of stuff
now you now you mean practically so
I mean I can tell you this problem is a
convex program at the end of the day if
your game is linear quadratic for
example this is a convex problem you can
reformulate it as an sdp but this sdp is
going to be dimension of number of
Agents so you know it is convex but if
your population is too large you won't
be able to solve it and just because you
say lq
in my perspective I'm
the cost function I want to be convex so
the the objective is concave
or you can reformally because if no I'm
just trying to see like if I follow the
econometrics the classical econometrics
argument I don't see why I need to be lq
Jane I I claim that any game this is a
convex program at any case not only in
lq
uh I mean honestly I haven't thought
about the general case but where the
general cases When J is a concave I mean
it is right this is a convex function
yes but you are kind of yeah you're
minimizing this convex function less yes
yeah oh yeah right yeah I mean I
honestly have worked the detail for the
linear quadratic case and I can tell you
this in that case I maybe come back soon
I see the problem with distribution with
everything I would like just a
clarification what means interact
ability yeah yeah this this means like
you know it's actually a convex nice
problem but the number of variables is
very big oh yeah sorry it's not being CS
per size
okay
um so what I wanted to mention however
is that you know even if you were able
to solve this network optimal policy it
is computational attractable you were
able to solve it this requires for you
to know the network right and so instead
we wanted to understand okay what
happens if my central planner doesn't
have this network information it only
knows where the network has been sampled
from
and so what we propose here is kind of
an alternative approach based on these
convergence that we have and so the idea
is to design a equivalent problem for
the infinite population so in the graph
on space and this is what that problem
would look like now of course I have an
infinite population here so my optimal
intervention is going to be a function
let me call it beta Head Start
now once I have that what I can do is
kind of design
um an intervention for the sample
Network where what I do is give to every
agent I an intervention that is
proportional to this optimal function
evaluated at the label UI of my agents
and what we've shown is that kind of a
corollary of the convergence result that
we have before is that this type of
intervention here is asymptotically
Optimum so again what is the big
advantage of this I just need to know
the graphone model to compute this type
of intervention instead of the network
realization
now of course the other thing that I've
mentioned before is that I want this to
be computationally tractable I want to
be able to solve it in order to apply
this you need to solve this optimization
problem and here it seems that made
things worse right because this is now a
problem in function space but what we
have are some nice results that if your
game has a nice structure like for
example the
um aggregate enters in a polynomial way
and if your graphone has a nice
structure for example it is finite rank
then you can actually solve this you can
reformulate it as an optimization
problem of small Dimension that you can
solve
okay and this is kind of an application
of this Theory so what we consider here
as a graphene is a stochastic block
model with four communities
um and what you see here is the
Improvement in welfare with respect to a
homogeneous allocation so homogeneous
allocation would be I give the same
budget to everyone forgetting about
natural information at all and here you
see like this case study for different
population sizes and here you have the
three type of intervention that I
discussed before right the network
optimal would be solve this problem that
really depends on the network that's of
course the best thing that you can do if
you're able to solve that problem but
you see here this was kind of me trying
to solve it on my laptop I wasn't
actually able to solve it when I have a
thousand agents
the network heuristic is this heuristic
that I mentioned based on factorial
properties that's of course nice to
compute you only need to compute the
dominant eigenvector
but the performance the grades with the
population size and then finally the
graph on optimal is the one based on
solving the problem for the graph on
optimization which in this case since I
have a stochastic block model with four
communities it's just an optimization
problem with four variables so it's
something you can really put for so
um and you see that you know this is
kind of the best of both work because
it's really easy to compute and it also
has very nice performance in terms of
welfare and in fact we are guaranteed by
our theorem that this is going to be as
important value
so kind of the summary of this part is
that using this graphene approach we can
compute intervention that are taxable
asymptotically optimal and do not
require information about the exact data
one question for the previous slide uh
they they sampling intervention that you
have I see a formula is a obvious why
this should be the the formula that you
would form it is a Formula that connects
the the solution that you have from the
graph and game to the I mean the
intuition for this is you know think of
this level here as the type of the agent
right so what is this telling me here is
what the best thing to do for each agent
depending on their type now when I
sample my network I assign a type to
each one of my agents so it kind of
makes sense that you know the
intervention that you should do you know
if I didn't have budget constraint would
be this right but then once you do this
then this will not stop exactly to the
budget that you have available so this
is just a normalization to make sure
that everybody that I actually use
allocate my entire budget in a way
that's proportional to what
I would do for the infinite population
again an optimization shares question do
we know that this is the optimal yeah
okay I just know that if you do this
I don't know for finite population I
mean actually no it's not optimal right
for final population what we would do is
solve this problem this is always going
to be better just
it requires you more information I meant
something like the the optimal
approximation if you follow the graphing
okay
so how do you know that your final game
has even a national equilibrium oh yes
that because remember the condition for
the equilibrium in the infinite game was
something that depends on the maximum
making value yes and once you sample
your network you know that the maximum
eigenvalue of the sample network is
converging to the maximum again value of
the graphone so if your population is
large enough the condition for existence
and uniqueness for the finite network is
going to be satisfied I see so you don't
need this notion of an Epsilon mesh you
really have set the Nash is optimal in
that sense and probably if you if you
didn't know the generating graph but
estimated that from network data yeah
you probably could prove that that still
works right I mean it would be an
Epsilon well no it would it works
exactly the same yeah I think so as long
as you know I mean it wouldn't be
asymptotically optimal it would be
there would be an error that depends on
the error of your estimation right if
you give me an estimate or that it's
really bad it won't work if the estimate
the procedure that you use for the
graphone estimation is converging to the
true graphone for large population then
this will work
right I imagine you draw K points K is
sort of you have a dense Network so if K
goes to Infinity you will get the graph
on that time better and then probably
your error in the end so maybe I could
ask it different if your graph on
if two Graphics change a little bit
how much does your yeah optimization
guarantee that that is like we have a
bound on that right because if you think
this was the empirical one but it could
be any other graph one right I like it
to if I look at the distance between the
graph or operator I know the distance
about the equilibrium and then the
results about the optimization is a kind
of dependent flows through yeah
okay
um so with that let me go to the second
problem
um and kind of a connection for that is
you know if you want to compute this
optimal intervention that we've
discussed so far we learned that you
don't need to know the exact Network you
cannot get away by knowing only the
graph phone but you need to know the
cost function of the agent to solve the
problem that I mentioned before so this
kind of ties me to this question which
is what happened if my central planner
also doesn't know exactly what the cost
function of the agents are but it kind
of can observe some equilibrium wants to
infer what else this agent optimizing
just by looking at the equilibrium
and this is some work that I've been
doing with the parasite how is a PhD
student at Cornell
um and so to kind of be a little bit
more precise suppose that your cost
function because the cost function we
discussed before is now parametric on
some parameter ETA and this parameter is
unknown to the central planner just a
very simple example to have in mind the
linear quality game that I discussed
before maybe this parameter Alpha how
much other people are affecting
microsfunction is unknown to the planner
and kind of there is a large literature
in economics that try to look at these
problems like kind of from equilibrium
recover what are the parameters of the
cost function starting you know from
this seminal paper that required exact
network data and then there's been
recent extension for kind of the
linearly mean model which is really
similar to kind of this linear quadratic
gain so again the point here is that the
network aggregate enters in an applying
way so what we wanted to try to address
is this problem but when uh you know we
have a genetic Network game as I
introduced in the first part of the talk
and again we don't know the network of
interaction
and kind of the idea is that again this
follows from the convergence result that
I mentioned at the beginning and why is
that the case but because we know that
the equilibrium that we observe is
actually converging to the graph on
equilibrium under the true parameter bar
right so again intuitively
in order to design an estimator for my
unknown parameter I could say well let's
speak the parameter for which what I
observe is as close as possible to a
graph on equilibrium with parameter ETA
so if I tune my parameter in order for
the graph on equilibrium to be as close
as possible as the observation question
so for finite then there should be n
parameters like right I mean one per
agent here we are assuming the parameter
is the same for all agents
let's see like if I go back this Alpha
here is actually the same for all agents
here okay
foreign
yes
okay
um okay so as I was mentioning this is
kind of our estimator now it's clear
that you know you cannot pretend to
solve this problem in any case right if
I have two different parameters that
generate exactly the same equilibrium
there's no way I can distinguish between
these two parameters from one
observation so that's why we introduce
this concept of parameter
identifiability really what this says is
if two graph from equilibrium are closed
the parameter that generated them should
also be close otherwise there's no hope
I'm gonna solve this problem
and so our main result in this R is that
under this type of assumption this
estimator that I introduced before is
asymptotically consistent what does this
mean this estimator will converge almost
surely to my true parameter as long as I
have large enough population
okay to save time I'm going to skip the
proof but it was just two lines
okay and this is kind of an illustration
that this works for this linear karate
game when I'm trying to estimate a bit
of X parameter
okay so with that let me kind of go to
the extension I promise I'm going to be
very quick in this
um so again one big assumption we made
so far is this assumption that we have a
unique Nash equilibrium however there
are games of Interest where that's not
true and so what we were thinking with
Kiran rocade who is another student at
um for now is well what happens in that
case can I still get some sort of
convergence
now in order to do that so in order to
allow for multiple equilibrium we relax
our assumption right so we don't require
any more this upper bound on the maximum
medium value of the graphone that was
what was giving us the contraction
um and in fact we can also Relax The
Assumption of the cost function have it
possible backs instead of strongly
convex
now of course we made our assumption uh
loser so we need to worry is it still
true that it mesh equilibrium exists or
not but it turns out that this is an
easy question to answer you can still do
a fixed Point argument you just need a
little bit more of a fancy fix Point
theorem to do that but everything kind
of goes through
the interesting question is what about
convergence of the equilibrium
and so what we have here is a first
positive result that says that if I have
a sequence of Nash equilibria in my
sample game that it's convergent that
will indeed almost surely converts to a
graph on equilibrium
and again not that this is kind of
interesting because now I'm talking
about [ __ ] converter right for any
fixed Network game I will have multiple
equilibrium but if I find a sequence of
this multiple equilibrium that converges
that is a graphical equilibrium and the
technical
step to prove that is to prove that the
best response mapping the one we were
studying before
um when I think of it as a function of
both the strategy profile and the
grapher as a closed graph if you do that
then please will immediately follow from
that
okay
um so this is nice but what about the
vice versa right if I give you a graph
on equilibrium is it true that you can
always find a sequence of Nash
equilibrium that will converge to it and
this I think is where kind of this
project became interesting because I was
extracting the answer to be yes but in
fact my student came out with counter
examples so this is not true that you
can have graph on equilibrium that
really pops up a delayed right they are
not sequence they're not the limit of
any sequence of sample Network equally
this is a very simple example of that so
I have a graphene where I just have two
communities and agents in community one
are only listening to agent in community
2 and vice versa and what the agents
want to do here is copy to time the
local average now kind of by homogeneity
it's easy to convince yourself that at
equilibrium in this game all agents in
community one will choose the same
strategy and all agents in community two
which is the same strategy so let me
call that X1 for agency Community one
and X2 for agents in community two then
the equilibrium condition from here is
that X1 should be equal to two times the
local aggregate Z1 but what is Z1 well
Z1 is just going to be all agents in
community two are playing X2 and I have
half of my agents there because I have
equal communities
and so you see that now this simplifies
so the condition is X1 equal to X2 so
this game actually has a mutated number
of equilibria pretty much as long as all
my agents are playing the same strategy
that's something
can I finish this I'll come to your
question after I finish this example
okay
um so this is what happens for the
infinite population now what happens for
the sample case
well in that case uh let me call Alpha n
the fraction of agents that are in
community two
then again because of homogeneity
Allegiance will play the same strategy
and the strategy of agents in community
one now needs to be two times the local
average in community one and the
interesting part is now what is this
well this is going to be how many agents
I have in community two and two times
the strategy x2n divided by the total
number of Agents so this is now two
alpha and x2n and now you see you have
two cases if alpha n is exactly equal to
one alpha you are back in the same case
as before everything is an equilibrium
as long as Everybody Plays the same
strategy but if alpha n is different and
a half then the only solution to this is
zero zero and why is this interesting
because when I sample my population I
have that infantry often in N I'm gonna
be in this case here so infinitely often
my game will actually only have the
equilibrium 0 0 so I cannot find a
sequence of equilibria in the sample
Network games that will converge to some
equilibrium that is not 0 0. so this
shows that basically I don't have this
convergence
I was just wondering whether there are
limits of approximate Nash equilibrium
yes they are exactly so this is kind of
what I reconcile my intuition that what
you can actually prove is that all
graphone equilibrium will actually be a
sequence of approximately so as long as
you allow your agents to be content with
kind of not doing exactly the best way
they can but absent to that then you can
actually find a convergence sequence
so so this is a totally aligned with
what we say in game theory that says
that
the Epsilon Nas equilibria are not
necessarily close to the Nancy of
Liberia absolutely okay yes yeah like
this game here is an example where you
have one zero zero but all the
strategies where all the agents play the
same is going to be an episode
for any Epsilon right you can make this
absolute as small as you want
okay
um so in just two minutes I'm gonna
flush this part
um this is some project that I've done
with Salman Errol from CMU and Alex
steibelbein from Oxford University
um and this is a little bit different
because here we're considering games
with discrete action stats so we don't
have this action set and in fact what we
are considering is a kind of uh this
coordination game that I introduced at
the very beginning
um so remember here agents
um want to adopt a technology or buy a
certain product if enough of their
neighbors have done so and so in this
type of game it's very interesting to
look at what are the so-called best
response Dynamics so what happens when
agents are trying to learn the national
equilibrium
um and this is going to be something
like this so I start with an initial set
of adopters the seed set and then I let
agents play their best responses so they
will adopt when enough of the neighbors
have adopted and why are these
interesting because this is a model of
kind of diffusion or contagion in
network that's what well studied is the
so-called linear threshold model
this has been studied a lot both in
deterministic and random networks and as
I mentioned at the beginning a very
interesting question is how do you
choose the initial seed set in order to
maximize contagion and this is a very
famous work from the Cs Community where
they show that you know agreed heuristic
is effective it's the pressure not
random this is another beautiful paper
that looks at this question over
configuration model so what we were
doing in this work is look at this
question when your network is sampled
from a graph
but you can kind of follow the same
procedure we did here so first take the
limit for infinite population Define
graph of contagion then show that kind
of the outcome of graphing contagion for
the infinite population is a good
prediction of outcome of graph of
contagion in Sample networks and then
use the process for the infinite
population in order to compute ceiling
policies and this is kind of how this
performs so what you see here is the
seeds that computed in terms of the
graph and policy this is as a function
of the population size the fraction of
final adapters you see this is kind of
what you really want because in this
case
100 of the people adopted at the end
right so this is the best possible
outcome and this is compared to the
greedy policy that I mentioned in the
paper before or a random policy where
you just pick your C that random and you
see that this instead like their
performance degrades with the population
size
okay so this leads me to the end of my
talk again what I've tried to convince
you is that it is interesting to use
this tool of graphon and you know random
graph theory in general to study what
happens in strategic setting over large
networks and I've kind of discussed
mainly this graph on game paper just
give you up two slides about graph and
contagion and if you are interested in
more about this we do have a review
paper where we discussed kind of a
little bit where the uh
what so thank you so much
thanks for the very nice talk uh
questions
thank you for the nice talk um I have a
question regarding the intervention part
where you solve the problem in the limit
I think you mentioned the we need some
structures on the cost functions and the
block structures yeah are these uh need
to be satisfied at the same time or one
of them yeah no at the same time yes I
see so yeah basically to make it
but basically you know like the cost
function of the linear quadratic game
there was a cost that needs to be convex
and then some marginal cost as long as
that marginal cost is polynomial in Z
that's fine and then your grapher needs
to be final Frank yes and again this is
sufficient condition so the general
problem how you solve that for General
graph on its open I think it's super
interesting but yeah
in the beginning you mentioned the
connection to the distribution of
centrality measures can you elaborate a
little on that yeah so if you have a
linear quadratic game
um like the one I showed you in the very
first slides the equilibrium of that is
going to be bonus centrality of the
player just compute bonuses centrality
of your player that's the equilibrium
okay and in fact another nice connection
maybe uh of that linear quality game if
you compute the best response Dynamics
that's going to be the the group uh
model of opinion Dynamics so that's kind
of as a side a lot of most of the people
started
maybe in the interest of time we'll take
the one final question when Sonia is
setting up
absolutely
out of curiosity a
the existence somehow says to me that
the membership of the equilibrium is
again in the ppad do we know if it is
complete so can I create a graph on that
will give me also the worst case
the bad example that we have the PPA the
hardness of the nas equilibrium from a
normal form game can I have that do I
know that the graph on equilibrium the
graphene equilibrium is PPA the heart
I honestly haven't thought too much
about it but I would say probably yes
because of this result that you can take
any fun and natural game and then put
that into another iPhone game so if you
have a network game finance that has
okay complexity I'm not totally familiar
with the graph function how the
continuity goes yeah but like it's not a
continuity thing you can just take any
fun and natural games and just you know
map that Constructor
okay so you can compute that Graphics
you will be able to compute the one so
the real question is if it is a member
because we can surely include the bad
distance
thank you
foreign